Pensavo che per fare la rivoluzione
occorresse essere
un personaggio particolare,
tipo Mao, Che Guevara o Ghandi.
Poi una sera, in realtà,
in un modo inaspettato
e molto semplice è cambiata la mia vita
e ho capito quale era
la mia missione nel mondo.
In realtà non è stato né per un boccale
di birra né per un incontro romantico,
come ci hanno raccontato
alcuni relatori prima, ma per un ortaggio.
Mi è andata bene, poteva andar peggio,
perché è stato grazie a un carciofo
quindi mi ritengo molto fortunata.
Magari a tanti di voi è capitato,
mentre cucinavate degli ortaggi,
di rendervi conto di quanto
si scarta ogni giorno,
di quanta è la percentuale di scarto.
È quello che è successo a me
una sera proprio grazie a un carciofo.
Questa cosa mi ha aperto la mente
e mi ha fatto un po' cambiare prospettiva.
Da quel momento ho deciso
che la mia missione nel mondo
sarebbe stata
non dare più niente per scontato
e cercare di rendere il mondo un po' più
sostenibile partendo proprio dal cibo.
Perché il cibo?
Il cibo è la cosa
su che abbiamo più libertà di scelta
è la cosa su cui possiamo decidere
per noi e per la nostra famiglia,
ogni singolo giorno,
è non solo quindi una questione di scelta
ma è anche una questione
di impatto ambientale
perchè le nostre scelte alimentari
di ogni giorno
costituiscono gran parte
del nostro impatto ambientale quotidiano.
Se vogliamo tradurlo con un indice
potremmo parlare di impronta ecologica
e incide molto di più quello
che scegliamo di ordinare al ristorante
che magari il modo in cui ci vestiamo
o come ci spostiamo per per la città.
Per questo motivo, credo
che sia importante
essere perfettamente consapevoli
delle scelte che si fanno ogni giorno
e magari cercare di cambiare qualcosa
e cominciare una piccola rivoluzione.
La mia parola d'ordine
è una molto semplice,
di buon senso: ottimizzare.
Direi che è quasi più una parola
che si riferisce all'economia domestica
che all'impatto ambientale,
però penso che sia
un concetto molto semplice
che si può ben applicare
alla vita di tutti i giorni
e soprattutto a quello
che è il nostro rapporto con il cibo.
Ottimizzare vuol dire ad esempio
il modo in cui facciamo la spesa,
quanto decidiamo di acquistare
quindi il concetto di comprare il giusto,
quello che effettivamente serve,
cercare di ridurre gli sprechi.
E poi cercare di usare
il 100% delle materie prime,
il concetto di ottimizzare consumi
e soprattutto il modo
in cui componiamo il piatto ogni giorno,
quindi che cosa
effettivamente portiamo a tavola.
Gli scarti; io sono partita
in questo progetto
dall'incontro con il carciofo
dalla fine della filiera, dei rifiuti,
da quello che solitamente buttiamo via.
Qui davanti avete un piccolo esempio
di scarto versus materie prime nobili.
Noi siamo abituati a fare quello che sto
facendo adesso tutti i giorni a casa
quando puliamo le verdure e a separarle:
da una parte c'è la parte nobile
che usiamo e dall’altra c'è lo scarto.
Lo scarto quindi, la parte meno nobile,
è in media almeno il 50%.
D'inverno arriviamo fino anche al 70%
perché tantissime verdure
hanno più parti protettive.
Che cosa vuol dire ottimizzare in cucina?
Vuol dire cambiare l'approccio al cibo,
usare il 100% delle materie prime,
ma non vuol dire semplicemente
recuperare queste cose dai rifiuti
vuol dire avere un approccio diverso,
vedere tutte queste parti
come un unico insieme.
Facciamo un esempio con la mela.
Io la mela posso vederla come una mela
ma passa anche vederla
come un insieme di 4 ingredienti,
per esempio la polpa
- per semplicità ho fatto delle cips
ma avrei potuto anche gustarla
così al naturale, o farci una torta-
la buccia -magari la sto mangiando
così com'è, oppure l'ho essiccata
e ci faccio
una tisana rigenerante fantastica
che se la compri in erboristeria
vi costa sicuramente di più -
il torsolo - lo centrifugo e lo lascio
fermentare con il succo al naturale,
diventa un buonissimo aceto di di mele
perché l'aceto
si può fare anche dai torsoli -
i semi, li posso usare come gelatificante.
Questo è solo un esempio, con un prodotto
che dovrebbe esservi familiare,
ma è il concetto che secondo me dovremmo
applicare ad ogni singolo ingrediente.
Un altro esempio, questo qui,
è uno degli ortaggi
che c'ho messo più tempo ad amare
al 100%: la zucca;
mi piace molto perché la buccia
è la vera parte nobile,
quella dove si concentra
la maggiore quantità di fibra,
è meno dolce della polpa
per cui magari se non vi piace
il dolce troppo spiccato della polpa,
potete concentrarvi sulla buccia ed
è anche la parte che contiene più fibre,
quindi un beneficio
sicuramente anche per la salute.
Ma non solo, con tutti i filamenti interni
posso preparare una cialda,
i semi, li posso tostare
o anche semplicemente far germogliare.
Il far germogliare una cosa
penso che sia un esempio pratico
di una tecnica facilissima
che permette di trasformare e valorizzare
qualcosa che abbiamo tutti in casa
e che solitamente non degnamo
di uno sguardo e che buttiamo via.
Quindi ottimizzare in cucina
per me è soprattuto questo:
cambiare un po' la propria mentalità
e vedere con un occhio diverso
gli ortaggi e tutto il cibo
per sprecarli meno
e valorizzarli al massimo.
Ottimizzare vuol dire anche ottimizzare
i consumi di acqua ed energia.
Per esempio, tutte le volte
che cuocio la pasta o delle verdure
posso in contemporanea cuocere
altre cose magari delle verdure,
basta avere un cestello
non è che serva chi sa che cosa.
Oppure tutte le volte che uso
un elettrodomestico come la lavastoviglie
usarlo anche per cuocere,
- e non è solo una provocazione,
sono sicura che qualcuno
di voi sta torcendo il naso,
ma è una tecnica di altissima cucina
la bassa temperatura.
Quindi non occorre che vi compriate
uno strumento professionale da 2000 euro,
potete usare la lavastoviglie
tutte le volte che lavate i piatti.
Come si fa?
Un esempio molto pratico:
prendete un vasetto come questo
deve essere a tenuta ermetica,
metteteci ad esempio un uovo,
coprite con dell'acqua e chiudete bene,
e lo riponete in mezzo ai piatti sporchi,
quindi la lavastoviglie comunque
deve essere piena di piatti sporchi,
e poi usate il lavaggio che preferite,
scegliete in base allo sporco
dei piatti e non viceversa.
Quando il lavaggio finisce il vostro uovo
sarà alla coque, sodo o bazzotto
in base al lavaggio che avete scelto.
Sarà fantastico perché sarà cotto
a bassa temperatura,
molto meglio del classico uovo sodo,
una consistenza incredibile!
E l'avete fatto a impatto 0, a costo 0
e in più ottenendo un risultato
che difficilmente si otterrebbe
con le tecniche tradizionali.
Quindi ottimizzare
anche l'utilizzo dell'elettrodomestico
può dare degli interessanti benefici.
Un'altra applicazione dell'ottimizzare,
questa volta vi entro ancora
di più in casa, nei vostri piatti.
Quando eravamo in guerra,
c'era penuria di un sacco di alimenti
avevamo poche proteine si mangiavano
un sacco di patate di polenta
e quando si potevano metter
a tavola delle carni, dei piatti proteici
era una festa e andava bene così.
Adesso invece il problema è opposto
abbiamo tantissima abbondanza
e abbiamo un po' la tendenza
a mettere nel piatto
il doppio delle proteine che ci servono.
Perchè è un problema?
È un problema perchè in realtà
se mangiamo troppe patate o troppa polenta
- magari mettiamo su del peso -
ma se mettiamo nel piatto troppe proteine
stiamo affaticando reni, fegato
e anche aumentando il rischio
di sviluppare alcune patologie.
Quindi è una cosa che non ci fa bene.
La classica porzione da ristorante
ma anche che ci facciamo a tavola
che può essere dai legumi, alle carni,
ai pesci, in realtà è troppo abbondante
mangiando tante verdura, in realtà,
copriamo gran parte del nostro fabbisogno
di proteine quotidiane.
Perchè ho inserito
questo concetto nel mio talk?
Perché mangiare più di quello che ci serve
è uno spreco di risorse.
È sicuramente qualcosa
che potremmo migliorare.
Se per di più queste proteine
sono proteine animali
che hanno un elevato impatto ambientale
ridurle vuol dire anche diminuire
il propio impatto ambientale
quindi penso che sarebbe importante
che tutti noi mettessimo
un po’ meno proteine nel piatto
sarebbe sufficiente
un piccolo sforzo da parte di tutti voi
per avere un importante beneficio
sicuramente ambientale
sulla nostra salute singola,
ma anche di tutto il nostro paese
e ancora di più
se lo facessimo a livello mondiale
anche in termini
di spesa pubblica per la sanità.
È un beneficio anche di benessere
del signolo e ovviamente per la società.
Credo che sia più efficace
cercare di convincervi a mettere
un po’ meno proteine nel piatto
che magari cerca di convincere tutti voi
ad abbandonare i prodotti animali.
Forse ne convincerei uno
mentre magari questa cosa
spero che vi rimarrà impressa
non dovete preoccuparvi
di mangiarne abbastanza
ma di non mangiarne troppe
questo è il problema
e soprattutto
cercare di mangiarle di qualità
e più possibile privilegiando i prodotti
animali con un basso impatto ambientale.
Quali? Vi starete chiedendo.
Beh… l'anno prossimo ci sarà anche l’Expo
e ci sono un sacco di persone
che parlano del cibo del futuro...
Io ho sentito tanto parlare di insetti.
Personalmente credo che non faccia
prorio parte della nostra cultura,
non so se siete d'accordo con me,
non siamo un paese mangiatore di insetti
e credo che difficilmente lo diventeremo
ma c'è invece un alimento proteico
che è assolutamente a impatto zero
che possiamo per di più
autoprodurre noi a casa nostra
e che per di più possiamo
nutrire di scarti vegetali
magari non quelli
che porteremo a tavola stasera
ma le cose che non riusciamo
proprio ad utilizzare.
Di cosa sto parlando?
Sto parlando degli ospiti a sorpresa
che sono con me sul palco
oggi ovvero di lumache,
che hanno un po’ sofferto dei climi rigidi
del Trentino, come vedete
e hanno deciso questa notte
di andare in letargo.
In ogni caso ne ho qui una rappresentanza.
Perché mi piacciono le lumache?
Perché chiunque le può autoprodurre,
sono un prodotto gourmet
della tradizione italiana.
In sala chi di voi
ha mai mangiato le lumache?
Chi non le mangerebbe mai?
Vedete, probabilmente 10 anni fa
questo numero sarebbe stato inferiore
e più mangiatori di lumache.
Circa 35 anni fa una legge
c'ha impedito di raccoglierle
- noi eravamo anche
raccoglitori di lumache -
ma soltanto di approvvigionarci
dai produttori professionisti
questo ha favorito un grande sviluppo
di produttori di lumache in Italia
e noi siamo uno dei paesi
che hanno l'eccellenza a livello mondiale
ci sono migliaia di produttori in Italia
non solo per l'uso alimentare,
anche perché vengono usate
per la cosmesi e per altri utilizzi,
ma è un alimento che chiedendo
anche ad amici chef,
ha veramente tantissimo da dare,
è estremamente versatile
ha un gusto estremamente delicato
basta sapere come fare.
Per allevare le vostre lumache
a casa vi basta un piccolo balcone
o un orto e un po' di terra,
una retina per non farle scappare.
Le lumache arrivano anche da sole
basta piantare dell'insalata oppure
potete prendere delle uova
e poi nutrirle con gli scarti vegetali
quindi ancora di più
azzerare gli sprechi alimentari
e due volte all'anno
avrete il vostro raccolto
in autunno e in primavera,
come un ortaggio.
Richiedono un tempo
di cottura di circa un'ora
e poi potete farne quello che volete
e quindi dalla bourguignonne,
l'escargot francese o ricette più nostrane
che possono dare soddisfazione.
È una carne povera di grassi
che ha moltissimi benefici
e che può secondo me diventare
non solo il cibo del futuro
ma anche un cibo del presente.
Spero che magari l'anno prossimo
se vi faccio questa domanda
ci siano più persone
in sala che le mangiano
e meno che non le mangerebbero mai.
Di sicuro richiedono
un piccolo cambio di mentalità
e superamento di pregiudizi.
Quindi rivoluzione sostenibile!
Io sono convinta che possa essere
alla portata di chiunque di voi
e che richieda veramente
un piccolo cambiamento
sicuramente un cambio di mentalità
e il superamento di pregiudizi
sono consapevole che chiedervi
di cucinare in lavastoviglie
mangiarvi tutte le bucce,
cominciare a mangiare le lumache
non sia una cosa così semplice
ma sono una persona molto ottimista
e quindi spero in realtà di avervi
se non altro incuriosito.
Meno proteine nel piatto, cambiare
il modo di vedere tutti gli ingredienti.
I benefici sono veramente tanti.
Quindi unitevi
a me e diventate rivoluzionari
perché i benefici sono veramente tanti
sono per la nostra salute,
per il benessere
e soprattutto per la felicità nostra
e del pianeta.
Grazie!
(Applausi)